[MUSIC PLAYING]
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello
and welcome to I/O Live.
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and I'm standing here
with Tim Sneath, a product
manager on Flutter.
Hi, Tim.
TIM SNEATH: Hi, Timothy.
How are you doing?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm doing
very well, thank you.
Let's talk about Flutter.
For those few developers
out there that
don't know what Flutter
is yet, what is it?
TIM SNEATH: Yeah,
so Flutter is a tool
kit for building native mobile
apps, for iOS or Android,
from the same code base.
It's open.
It's open source.
And today at I/O,
we're announcing
a new version of Flutter.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, yeah, so
that was my next question.
What's new this week?
There's a new version.
What else?
TIM SNEATH: Yeah, so this
week we're announcing Beta 3.
Obviously, it's the third
beta of our product.
We shipped the first beta
at Mobile World Congress
a couple of months ago.
And now we're starting
to get to the point
where we really feel like it's
ready for a lot of production
use.
And so we're encouraging
people to start
taking a look at Flutter.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Now, you've
worked with developers
using Flutter a lot.
What would you say they're
most excited about when
they start using Flutter?
TIM SNEATH: Yeah, so I think
there are three things,
primarily, that make Flutter
a great platform for building
apps.
Number one, we have
native performance.
We compile everything that
you write to ARM code.
We're powered by the Dart
programming language,
and that enables this
really fast performance.
The second thing is we have
this unrivaled productivity.
With Flutter you can use
this thing called hot reload.
So you can write your code.
You can continue to work with
it and see exactly the changes
that you're making in
real time on the device.
And then thirdly, Flutter has
this high-velocity graphics
engine that lets your
dreams come true--
lets designers choose
what they want to build,
and developers put
them into production.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
Awesome, and there's
a lot of people
using Flutter today.
What are some of your
highlights of the apps that
are out and live?
TIM SNEATH: Yeah,
so again, we've
only just got into beta over
the last couple of months.
We had a few great
applications that
have come out, both internally
at Google and externally.
Internally, we power
some things like ads.
If you have ever
created an ad campaign,
you're using a Google
app built with Flutter.
Externally, probably
the most famous one
that was shipped at the backend
of last year was Hamilton.
You know, the Broadway musical.
They shipped a
companion app using
Flutter that has had
millions of downloads--
a really great application.
And then this week we're talking
about some other new apps.
Alibaba, the big
Chinese online retailer,
they have just shipped
an app in Flutter
that they're now rolling out
to millions of customers.
Groupon have an app
that they're working on.
We have just different
kinds of apps
from different industries--
wine, retail, finance.
Loads of different people
are coming out with apps.
And in fact, we've just
seen several hundred apps,
just since we shipped beta,
go live on the Play Store.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: If you want
to get started with Flutter,
what's your first step?
TIM SNEATH: Well, there's
one simple place you can go
and that's flutter.io.
And there you can find sessions.
You can find codelabs.
We're obviously live-streaming
six different sessions here
at Google this week.
There's a whole bunch
of documentation.
And of course, you can
download the Flutter SDK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
that's all at flutter.io.
TIM SNEATH: Flutter.io.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you, Tim.
TIM SNEATH: Of course,
it's a pleasure.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm Timothy
Jordan, and this is I/O Live.
[MUSIC PLAYING]